This table is covered in scum
This is not a sponsored thing at all. Can you imagine?
[bing, bong]
Hello, and welcome back to America-
Hello and welcome back to the universe's favorite game show. Will *cough cough*
Oh god!
The universe's favorite game show:
Will it 'kini!
*cough*
Suddenly my body is trying to stop me
from moving forward and producing this video.
You can't stop me body, even though you constantly try.
The game show in which I take three household items
and try to see if I can make a bikini out of them
The last episode I tried to make 'kini's out of...
What did I try to make 'kini's out of?
Old jeans, a paper bag and old dog toys.
This time I took your suggestions
and our contestants for this episode of will it 'kini are...
Aluminum foil, tin foil, aluminum wrap?
An old pillow case
and some old socks
The only rules to this game show is that
I try to make bikinis using whatever I have in my house.
And then we see if it keeps you
from seeing my bacon bits. [laughs]
Let's begin!
Round one!
I'm gonna start with tin foil.
I think this will 'kini but I think it's going to be painful.
Nips will be sliced.
Let's try it!
Again, you would think that I would have
more of a game plan in going into this, but no way.
Ooh.
This is going to hurt my cooter.
That's not the official tag line of "Will it 'kini" yet...
We're still workshopping.
But, it's a pretty good one.
How, do we get this to 'kini?
I'm just gonna let the foil speak to me
about how it wants to 'kini.
Ohhh.
It's 'kini time!
*music*
M'kay.
Let's...glue them...together?
Ow!
Metal does absorb the heat very quickly.
Kay...
Ooh
A dream of mine has always been to feel like
a really sexy human baked potato.
Kay... So we're hanging' a little low.
If this YouTube thing doesn't keep panning out for me, uhh,
get ready local high schools,
I'm coming for your art teaching position.
Or science.
If the Tin Man was The Bachelor,
I'm gonna look like one of the contestants,
...on that season.
Okay we have our top... sorta...
We're gonna let that be... over here.
Now, the bottoms.
*music*
I think I... didn't size my bottoms right.
Like a real, modest 'kini bottom.
Real trough for my cooters I might say.
We're gonna let that sit and move on to our other 'kini!
Next we have this old pillow case which
I think will probably be the easiest to 'kini
because its fabric.
Get out of here my homemade chastity belt!
I have ideas for this.
'Cause if this is already sewn here,
I just need to cut up like that.
Ugh, okay!
*music*
Slam!
Woah, okay
But I think this might fit weird,
So I'm gonna cut these seams.
Adding some fabric to the side, so I could potentially
Just tie them up on the sides.
Basically cheating, but there are no winners here.
Just.
One.
Loser.
It's always good to be self aware.
I know it doesn't look like it,
but the bikini bottom made from the pillowcase is done.
Let's move onto the top.
Let's just f**k it.
We're just gonna try, something, okay?
*music*
I know this looks like I'm just cutting s**t
And that's... exactly what it is.
No, I have a plan...
*music*
Sorry that this pillowcase is so wrinkled, you guys.
It's truly the most embarrassing part of this video.
*music*
Okay! We have like a 'kini top!
But I worry that it's very see-through.
So I'm gonna, um, just hot glue on
some fabric to the underside of it
to make the tittay coverage
slightly less... transparent.
Okay! I think that our pillowcase 'kini is done!
We'll put that to the side.
Now it's time for our last 'kini.
Sock 'kini!
I've been making all these 'kinis
in the same sort of silhouette
So I'm wondering if there's a more interesting 'kini
I can make with these.
F**k, what can I do?
Speak to me dirty, old socks!
That's not a 'kini, at all. Just start cutting.
*music*
Here's an idea. That's gonna be bad.
Needs... more... bikini...
Worried about the sock 'kini, guys.
More glue!
This seems pretty bad!
We're gonna let that figure out what it wants to be.
Let's see if we can figure out this top part.
*music*
This could 'kini...
Feelings about sock 'kini might have come around.
Sock 'kini might not sock/suck!
(cheap one, Grace)
I had to, I'm sorry.
I get one, I'm done.
Okay! I think all of our 'kinis have been made
to the best that they're gonna be
for this moment in time, in this household.
Time to see will they 'kini!
'Kini number one! [snaps fingers]
Top half kinda 'kini's, bottom half...
Uh-uh!
Oh no, now the top half doesn't!
*chuckling*
[snaps fingers]
It 'kini's!
Well there you go, guys.
There's another episode of "Will it 'kini"!
We are basically 2 to 2 and a half for 3 this time!
If you like this video, give it a thumbs up
and leave some comments about what other items
I should try to 'kini!
Don't forget to click subscribe,
and hit that little bell so you get notifications.
'Cause I post videos inconsistently on a Monday, Wednesday, and Friday basis.
I don't know.
I'm just a girl at home
making some cheap 'kinis,
making cheap 'kinis, making cheap 'kinis!
Girl with a college degree making 'kinis.
By... herself, not even her dog
is actually here at the moment.
Download that on iTunes.